Understood
I will prepare for acceptance
Escaped prisoners
or habitual criminals with a tag
13 Call the chief surveillance officer, beginning with the car Sugoroku Morning
star today 1 Call
this to Riku-sama Anma Prison
[music]
ana
n ame
[music]
aname
me
[music]  [music]
nocare
[music]
me
ani
[music]
ana
Even now, you can continue to shoot
narai Come in a
small size
[music]
me
ano
Hmmm let's go together w Please help me two
[Music] It's
my real barrier.
It's
okay, even if I say something to you,
this guy won't listen to me at all.
[Music]
You guys are called Bach
.
Karashi
[music]
Guria It's a male character
Moogie with a needle It's my fault he's handsome He's being played around Maybe
I'm not suited for this job Maybe I should
quit and look for another job?
Or maybe it's
because you should try a little harder If you're going
to make a sound at this job, what kind of profession is
it?
I mean, if you can work here, you can
do it wherever you go No
way, I'll teach you how to treat them
Hopper
If you do this, their ability to take action should
be halved.
It's okay if I keep a clipping of
the
next number 69.
The ground is stretched, it's
not average
If you give it something like today's cafeteria menu to put something in,
it's the nature of being quiet for a while
.  In other
words, it's the hardest thing to do, or if you make an anime, you can leave
it as it
is.
If you let go, it's all about Tsuboguchi--this guy's special skill is a country that stands up, so he's
definitely going to jailbreak, so he
has a big blind spot.
It's
easy to catch even if
you run away from it The trick is to catch the other 3 people with the method just
before, then tell them to take a nap and take a nap
Job description more like a nursery teacher than a guard
Look at it, it should have an effect, then I'll come
. Is it a new prisoner?
What do you think, Panahana should break out of prison
? What will happen if this man enters?
Commander,
what are you aiming for?
I know how to
deal with it, you're working fast a Cutout from this month's survey for women's
magazines I was told to bring two days' worth of menus, sweets, and anime information magazines, so I'm asking
.
After that, the 15th number, which is only for the country that stands for the time being, is to meet in the courtyard in 15 minutes
and go to catch it.
Yes, prepare to have a new prisoner enter the 13th bar in the afternoon.
I heard that a newcomer is coming here.
What is the spirit?
If
you're a human, please finish 4 turtles oi with that kind of person That's right
c Eat
Lida Can you read it as an outburst?
It's strange I got
it, it's so detailed
Itoai ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
pony creator as
expected a poly book burger
It's a period drama
Today, even today, I'm not defensive
Shuriken is a smacker
Disney-chan
Hey, you didn't come here with a gun and sword law violation gray, did you?
I'm really curious about the situation
when I was caught.  What kind of road is the cage
movables? Are you the same escaped prisoner?
[Music]
I'll decide who's the better prison breaker at the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll show you the difference in ability It's like a blur
8 If you're overworked,
it's the time of the ox tonight.
After dinner, when I went to ask for orders, I was completely moved
.  This is a prison escape match, isn't
it? People in the 4th grade go to the shadows and always act
as shadows, don't they?  hey  I don't
show my hand to love on the day of investment
I
'm sure from now on I'm sure you guys are fine What's up with it?
Is it a jailbreak during the tour month?
Hey,
what's with care?
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, we didn't escape from prison in the first place.
When using it,
the technique of power generation
is ah, oh, only Hanapapa is doing
Alice, and Dero Jean Maril's canter
is truly a scaled
hole slave
of Number Prison.  It's not coming, but it's a
game He's selfishly breaking the strongest jailbreak, Liar,
you've definitely seen that convention If you can
escape from this place, it's a match-making link
This is a thread
Matcha is good
aname
I'm sorry,
I wrapped it around myself. When I
buy it, I
'm actually looking at my house during late-night training.
When he's in front of the camera,
he shaves his head. That Shinji looks like he's a movie star, but he seems to know exactly where the camera is
.  Everyone is back on the 13th road
.
Well then, it's Noriaki Oh,
my Soma family, don't listen to me seriously.
Shuzasa
[Music] There's
really no cherry blossom viewing in the main story.
We'll
do it, shouldn't the guards do it? I'm in charge of cleaning the cherry blossoms at headquarters. Excuse me
.  Excuse me, let's get started. Do
n't give
me orders
.
First, Chief Jailer, your Cao Ren was
staring at me like
crazy.  Ashton A number prison special event is held once
a year.Those who are preparing for foot fukuji are watching volume 4 without pulling out.The
representative senbatsu of scholars has been decided.
Hey, what a beautiful expression at the
top Master, you look down on everything.  I've missed it
this year, I'll take
revenge Haa, 13 minutes from the secretariat, that guy's pet Komachi-
chan, that kid It's not a joke, 13 sticks are the representative Follow me, and my turn will increase
Can you do it easily?
The love side was good I want to see red and white
tomorrow from New Year's food
to Kiko  From now on, I'm going to play
poker.It's the last job of the
year
.  How many times have we been together for the first time in a long time
?
Yeah, it was a good year. See you next year.
[Music] The
city bus is
wonderful!
It's going to be exciting
goo
If you think there are 8 dogs with bullets, you'll lose them, and if you think you're going to stop them, it's safe, so you can use bad laws without permission
.
[music]
ani
yeah yeah yeah [music] none goo ni cuni
[music]
[applause]
i am
[music]
car
tan
Trust has come to Nanba Prison Let's play anime-like games on New Year's Day
Come quickly, let's open next time
From here on, the serious New Year's body enters
What was it until now?